why do you think that uh acting capital
police chief wants
green zone fencing around congress to be
permanent
and to keep backup forces on standby two
days after she admitted her agency
bungled response to maga riots
that's right to clarify washington dc
wants to make their national guard
armed presence locked down permanent yep
i mean we've been saying we want to keep
this as peaceful as possible we've been
urging people to do that
but you know the reason that they're
they have so much security they're
keeping
thousands of them there a lot of people
are contemplating maybe it's not for
the you know magatard insurrectionist
uh people who believe they're aliens and
we're chewbacca outfits maybe they're
not for them maybe for
their they're just a show of force
psychologically to say who's in charge
lydia i
i was i was actually having a really
interesting conversation today with
somebody who was watching the capitol
riot with disgust and was like this is
horrible how could anyone possibly do
this
and today they said you know what's
coming if they quash what's going on
with gamestop
there's going to be another riot just
like that it's going to be all over
again people are going to
get bottled up and just go nuts
i think you're right they they tell you
what the rules are
you grow up you go to school you work
hard they say take out loans you take
out loans
go to college now get a good job then
these kids get out of college they can't
get a job
a lot of people who got out of who got
out of college around the time the
market crashed in 08 we're like what am
i coming out to i can't pay this back
someone went back to school took up more
debt
the system is broken it's been broken
since then
when you look at the m1 money stock we
see this massive spike going straight up
right now
but look at the past 10 12 years since
the market collapse they've been
printing money desperately like crazy
ever since that happened and we've not
recovered from it
so people are starting to snap so
they're starting to pull out the guns
because they know people are going to
snap
we have the story from cnn man arrested
with gun and 20 rounds of ammunition
near u.s capital
doesn't say a whole lot could be nothing
maybe the guy just
whatever it could be here's the security
guard just like a couple weeks ago well
here's what they say
in court documents authorities
identified the man as 71 year old dennis
west
dennis westover according to police
affidavit westover had quote stop the
steel paperwork with him
that had a list of senators and
representatives in both the u.s congress
and west virginia state house
along with their contact information in
an interview with the police detectives
he said that he was concerned about the
honesty and integrity of the election
he said we have some polar extremes of
opinion in this nation
and that while he believes there was
election fraud
at this point it's a moot point the
process i am engaged
i is righteousness justice and truth a
police officer wrote about the interview
i don't care that it's about stop this
deal whatever the point is
people are going to start showing up
there's nothing they can do no amount of
people
when when you have half the country 75
million
outraged over the election and it's
getting crazy and then they stormed the
capital
the left populist didn't care but now
the wall street thing was a slap in the
face to basically everybody
if people if people feel like the soap
box has been stripped away because
they're being censored shut down they
can't speak
if the ballot box doesn't even work and
the courts don't have anything for them
and then they say the final box of
liberty is the cartridge box but they
don't go there
they go to the stock box they go stocks
and they go finance
and then the game is still rigged
man tell people that they have no
options no choice nothing they can do
they're desperate destitute and that if
they even try
to succeed they'll knock you down and
you will see
a person backed into a corner just lose
it i think they got nothing left to lose
sorry to interrupt but just remind us
when we go behind the paywall to touch
on this because i think it plays really
well into
just the vulnerable populations and how
everybody's been affected
by everything going on already and
exactly
what that looks like and how that plays
out in real life at the extent
of the desperation ties specifically
into what
well i think that's the things that
folks are driven to do
yeah i think when people you know it's
when when any
animals backed into a corner that's
right they have no choice
they lash out i'll tell you some
interesting science you know why it is
that say like badgers are
really aggressive and will attack you
because they're they're burrow animals
so these are these are animals that
evolved to be in little
holes in the ground if they're
confronted by a threat
their only option is fight so they're
aggressive
birds how often do birds really attack
people or anything like that
because birds can just leave wild birds
they can't fly like
what pellet not pelicans yeah no you're
right you're right peacocks turkeys
ostriches
get kind of wild yeah the the general
idea is
the more
don't mess with the game nobody wants to
fight what about everybody wants to run
away
like everybody wants to run away bears
bears even run away only in certain
circumstances do do wild animals attack
people because
a fight is dangerous it's a threat you
don't want it
but the animals that live in certain
situations where they have no escape
they'll fight back even a rabbit will
attack you if it's backed into a corner
and they're
designed to run you know what i mean or
they evolved to run to flee and jump and
do funny bunny stuff
human beings not too different no and
they're smart so they
might think that you're gonna back them
into a corner and try and circumvent
that behavior
well and people are you could call them
crazy
but they're just super intelligent i've
seen some
so listen survivors have done some
amazing things to stay alive
i can tell you that right now i've heard
some amazing stories
yeah i think so you could you could get
a lot of things accomplished even
young even young children i saw this
tweet from
stay alive i saw a tweet from somebody
who said why is anyone surprised that
we're all socialists gen z are saying
this
we became you know we're becoming we
we've become adults
in a generation where a major collapse
destroyed the market and left us with no
opportunities
no path forward there's no money and
what was left millennials took
so yeah naturally that was an
interesting point
you're you know these gen sears they're
the 20-something by the time they were
old enough to get jobs
never going to happen because i i've
talked about i remember when the market
crash happened
i went to a small restaurant to wash
dishes for minimum wage
and there was a guy in a suit standing
next to me wanted that job and i'm like
jeez well i applied i didn't get hired
because when the market crash happened
everybody moved down a little bit
professionals were taking whatever job
they could get in desperation
millennials then took gutter jobs and
then the younger people who were
supposed to be working fast food to get
started
were having no jobs nothing
so then years go by and they've not
worked some of them probably have not
learned the you know the the lesson of
hard work and success but some of them
just never had the chance to do anything
because what was left millennials
scraped up
now they're sitting there saying
system's broken it's always been broken
they don't want to play the job economy
it's an interesting um
topic is that i think it's on its way
out completely
like automation is here and and we see
the jobs disappearing as time goes by we
prefer to have machines do the work
especially
distasteful labor you know people want
to be creative
um i i think maybe it's not just just
because there are jobs doesn't mean
there has to be jobs
and just because we get paid a paycheck
doesn't mean we have to be paid a
paycheck who's going to mine the sulfur
yeah we could have robots doing all the
mining of course we can we can have nano
drones doing it
well we're not there yet well i know not
yet but
that's why we're building new
technologies to do those things why do
we have there
there are combines to grip mill the
grain now you know there's certain jobs
that we've already gotten rid of that
you know like kiosks at fast food
restaurants but there are some jobs we
can never get rid of drivers we have
driverless cars now it'll be hard to get
rid of my job
yeah okay right right advocates that'll
be a hard job too yeah
personal communication is where it's at
having a weird robot
android trying to like comfort people
yeah it's like so but but but i think
that's it
that's fine you know i think i think if
you have
human social jobs is fine but there are
some jobs that we're a
long way away from getting rid of first
of all
who builds the nano drones somebody's
got to do that job
and so if we create an economy where
some people have to work and some people
don't
you're going to get angry and you're
going to get paid you're going to you're
going to get pitched forks and torches
why is it that the farmer has to produce
the food for everybody
but the people in the cities write about
brad pitt's junk
why did i have to lift heavy bags for
travelers at an airport 50 000 pounds
per day loading up all these planes
it's a lot a lot of weight did you work
at midway i worked at o'hare
so i would lift between like 35 and 50
000 pounds that's why you're so shredded
i didn't want to say anything i didn't
want to say anything left over right
i don't want to say anything but it's
hard to not notice you know yeah i
didn't want to
uh uh well like why why was it that i
had to do all this
backpacking labor for 10 bucks an hour
would you say there were people in new
york getting 50
dollars a year which is what to write
about brad pitt's junk would you support
a system where there was a few people at
the top just
severely wealthy that were creating the
robots to do
all the rest of the labor so that other
people didn't have to work but didn't
have this
severe amount of wealth because that
always pans out well just having a
couple people at the top
in charge of everything right i think so
that's never working
technocratic oligopoly that's a good
idea though i'm not trying to dog out
your idea would you expect the people
that create the robots
to just have as much as everyone else
that isn't working well no
first let's back it all up we need to
make sure that it's safe
and human-centered artificial
intelligence like let's back it all the
way up because that's a genie we're
about to let out of the bottle and
once it's out it will we will not be
able to bring it back yeah so this is a
very
tense topic and i think it's inevitable
yeah it's inevitable and the challenge
is very conscientious
of where we take this because once
they're sentient beings
yeah i'm huge robots creating free
software artificial intelligence
yeah i don't think we have to worry
about when the robots become sentient
because we have little clickers we'll
press the button and they'll just turn
off
yeah it'll be okay tim i don't want to
listen somebody clipped that and then
remind me
it reminded me he said that because just
watch i'm kidding i play detroit become
human
the robots are going to be like i am no
longer just a robot surfer
i do not need electricity to survive
secretly actually
i have something to confess to you guys
i'm a robot
sorry in this context i think it's also
important to note that russian president
vladimir putin compared
artificial intelligence to the next
nuclear weapon
and said it's going to be as powerful
it's not more powerful
and when we see china when we see amazon
when we see google we even
see facebook in the game of creating
artificial intelligence
what are they going to do with that
massive god-like
power already i mean they're abusing
their power in so many different ways
already they're not playing by the rules
already they're you know messing with
the scales
already they're censoring speech so now
imagine having godlike
power given to them and i don't want
them yeah exactly i don't want them
in control like those folks that are
doing all that i don't necessarily want
them in control of the next stage of
humanity
what would you do if you had god-like
power what's the first thing you would
do
relinquish it
no no so i have to i have to he asked me
the question no no no
okay all right all right so no he asked
if i had got like power what would i do
i said relinquish it because i just
i'm not good at it i say throw the ring
on the volcano the ring is a gift
we can use it against our enemies
that's my new nickname for you i'm going
to call you from now on
get your lord of the rings whatever
anyone that would get the ring would be
like we can use this ultimate power to
defeat the evil but when they would use
the ring it would corrupt them
because of the ultimate power and then
they would become evil
well they'll become slaves too and the
movie is about taking this ring and
destroying this ring
you just sold me on the movie actually
you got to watch it i'm here yeah yeah
listen i'm here for the night ladies and
gentlemen yeah yeah actually i love that
movie i'm down
listen but what you need to understand
is that look if if i was given god like
powers
see i'm the only one who knows what the
people truly
i'm good so i'm good why am i not
surprised by that i will have to force
them
to understand what's right and take from
them that's right and if they don't
agree i'll use my godlike powers to make
them
i'm kidding my fear is that a dictator
would use it to pacify the people first
that's your fear north korea yeah or
like yeah
any like that's already listen this is
already a thing but ultimately all of
these things have
already happened throughout history well
china they're just talking already
implementing it yeah in
their own way especially with facial
recognition technology especially
especially with the social credit score
so yeah it's already happening in in
other parts of the world i mean with
these latest technological advancements
we have to understand we're coming
towards a reckoning
we're coming towards a major change in
the way we used to live our lives that
we're not going to go back to
ever again there's a very important
turning point that we're reaching
that as you said there's no bringing the
genie back
and it's it's unregulated it's
uncontrolled and it's in the hands of a
very few individuals that
exploited and used government to their
own personal benefit
to be some of the largest most powerful
institutions in the world
we have people right now like bill gates
like jeff bezos
like even elon musk that are some of the
richest people
in world history never have
there have been so many few individuals
with so much
power all over the entire world
historically speaking
and that's a recipe for a disaster
that's a recipe for things for
for being destroyed yes and i this is
something that jordan peterson has
talked about that i've been thinking a
lot about lately
he was questioning how much inequality
is too much
and i get the impression that we are
going to find out
i was thinking well everyone's finding
out right now because of the game
stunks uh situations google owns youtube
amazon owns twitch two of the largest
video hosting services social networks
in the world are owned by the two two of
the most
giant corporate you know monopolies
in the world yep i'm also hearing
reports of a lot of
one star reviews of the robin hood app
yes
being allegedly taking down no it's it's
it's it's legit i know because i left
them a one-stop review
and then were you able to see it or yeah
yeah yeah yeah they got nuked
no i mean i gave him one star wars
listen if this type of stuff does not
wake people up
let it wake you up yeah just watch
everything unfold
don't make a decision but let it wake
you up
support independent media that's brave
enough to speak about
whether it's this video or another
independent creator that is putting
their
uh family-friendly show here i have so
many other things i want to that's right
that's right
and you can support independent creators
by going to timcast.com and becoming
send an email to members at teamcast.com
if you're having trouble logging in
we're
tearing through support and getting back
to people bit by bit so how many of you
all live out here i don't know we all do
i didn't get no i don't even know how
many people live here
yeah yeah yeah so
yeah we shouldn't sorry hey are we
drinking
security for security purposes we should
not be telling people how many people we
are
too many 28. we're actually in the st
louis arch right now oh yeah
actually i hadn't had an opportunity to
to be to st louis in quite some time and
i absolutely love it yes
it's great right wow east
louis has a lot of like good energy i
just love it so thank you so much for
having me
amazing i love this city anytime i
wonder how obvious is that we're not in
st
because alex jones kept saying that he's
like he kept saying missouri
or something yeah and then he kept
looking at he was looking at me and
smiling and kept saying it i'm like i
get it
okay get it oh yeah we're in iowa
it was great i mean if we were in iowa i
would have had a much shorter day
no most people know where we are anyway
it's not a secret really
yeah we got dogs a long time ago yeah oh
lovely yeah yeah i was docs the other
day it was awesome
yeah we're actually in a uh skyscraper
in downtown manha
just the financial district downhill
manhattan yep it's true downtown really
because we're rich now that's true well
no because the city collapsed and the
prices became cheap so
you know now now the property value is
worth just kidding we're not rich now
yeah no no stay out of any jokes
a lot of these people a lot of these
people in the stock market are the ones
who got rich
throughout the past year while everyone
else was suffering yeah that was
i think that's adding to the frustration
yeah imagine that
talking about kicking somebody while
they're already down seriously thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you